welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this episode
we're breaking down all of the insane
details and get out since its release
the film has received a lot of acclaim
and it was even nominated for several
awards including Best Picture at the
2018 Oscars the movie is laced with the
ton of foreshadowing and Easter eggs
that really elevate it above a lot of
Horrors throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the best of
them and discussing some of the hidden
meanings within the film there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to check out the movie yet
then I highly recommend that you get out
that's that's my one and only bad joke
of the video I promise make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day
and please drop a thumbs up if you enjoy
it without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
breakdown of get out okay so if you
haven't seen the film and are watching
this video for whatever reason I'll give
you a quick overview of the plot we
follow Chris a young photographer who
goes to visit his girlfriend Rose
Armitage his family upon arriving there
strange things begin to happen and he
unearths that the Armitage's have
developed a procedure in which they can
transfer the minds of people into shell
bodies Chris is the next target
and he's auctioned off to the highest
bidder and hypnotized into being
submissive however he manages to escape
before they can carry out the procedure
and he kills the family ending the film
that's a brief overview but it's just to
get you up to speed before the breakdown
and the movie opens with Andre Hayworth
walking through a suburban area at night
whilst he's on the phone to his
girlfriend
Andre becomes a prominent figure later
in the film and we learn that he was
actually subjected to the same procedure
that Chris narrowly escapes from the car
drives by him and it begins to
intimidate him before abducting him now
there are a couple of things to take
from the scene Bruce Lee Rose is clearly
on the phone to him and this is how the
car is able to track him the person on
the phone says stay put
we'll come and get you - which Andre
replies with there's no need he gives
his location and then they show up Andre
got lost looking for peacock Avenue and
is likely that these direction
- a fake peacocking is a term that is
often used to describe a male trying to
attract a mate but here it could be
twisted round two rows attracting andre
to this spot so that jeremy can abduct
him the film is about taking messages
and subverting them and I definitely
think that this holds a double meaning
here another interesting aspect is that
the car that Jeremy drives is white on
the outside and black on the inside this
is of course a nod to the fact that
black people are later sent to the
sunken place whilst a white person and
habits their shell from here we cut to
the title scene which has blue writing
over the top of a forest which is
intentionally meant to be a nod to the
shining which is one of peels favourite
films after the brief credits sequence
we can hear this song redbone by
childish gambino not only is it a banger
it also has some elements of the song
that play out here which foreshadow the
rest of the film the parts that we hear
contain the following lyrics from the
song but stay woke as in don't go to
sleep Chris they gon find you go and
catch you sleeping as in don't go to
sleep Chris I'm telling you and the
chorus ends with now don't close your
eyes again highlighting this point I
think I think I've officially got my
StreetPass now for using the word goal
now as we tour his apartment we can see
a white child wearing a dog mask and
peering out from behind it this once
more is a reference to the white people
wearing black people as a mask in the
film upon Rose arriving there we can see
a chain that looks slightly like an
unlock slave handcuff and though I may
be reading into this I think it
highlights that Chris eventually ends up
free from the family after almost
becoming their slave Rose sits about
with the dog and then puts it down
saying that she has to price something
out of its dad this is possibly
referring to his brain which they try
and pry out at the end of the movie here
they talk about her family and the line
my dad would have voted for a bomber at
the time if he could have this line
appears again later in the film and it
could show that a lot of things that the
Armitage is talked about are scripted
because they've went through the process
numerous times on a side note I would
have voted for a bomber a third time if
I could have so thumbs up the thumbs up
buttons right there now this idea of
voting for Obama is contested later in
the movie at the party when we see that
all of the guests wear something with
read on it this is except for Chris and
Andre they both wear blue so it could
represent Democratic versus Republicans
as these are the colors that both
parties tended on I don't know much
about American politics but if I did I
would have voted never mind the pair hit
a deer out on the road and this almost
causes a car crash the deer lies by the
side of the road at dying and this
reminds Chris of the death of his mother
which we'll get into in just a bit now
Chris actually seems to straw over this
where his rose doesn't really care
showing her disregard for life a police
officer arrives and asks for their ID
and Rose gets angry that Chris's ID is
asked for - and she kicks up a fuss with
the policeman we know from what happens
in the movie that Rose actually argued
over this because should Chris be listed
as missing
the officer may remember his name and
the car that he was riding in the
license plate would to lead back to Rose
and the Armitage's
and though she talks him down from
checking out who Chris is they arrive at
the house and there are two Omega
symbols outside of it according to
Google Omega is the last letter of the
Greek alphabet but most of the time in
English Omega is used as a symbol of the
last best or final nature of something
so it could show that this is the end
for Chris now the Armitage is ultimately
view possessing african-americans as the
best thing to do for their final nature
I'm not really seen anyone pick up on
this one either but it could also be a
reference to American colleges which
sometimes have a mega in their house
names colleges are also a sign of
privilege and this might be a reach but
it could signify their elite miss anyway
there's a ton of things outside the
house and inside the house that for
shallow how the family view themselves
and they drop a couple of lines to show
their ulterior motives Dean goes off on
a rant about how he hates Diaz and bucks
and after researching this speech on
reddit I discovered that a black book
was a term used for black men who
refused to bow to white Authority and
this adds a lot of weight to the
conversation Dean gives a tour of the
house and points out his family photo
which contains an image of his mother
and father the servants are nowhere to
be seen in this and we later learned
that both of his parents were put into
their bodies the fact that the servants
are missing yet Dean states that they
are so dear to the family
hence that they never actually existed
as part of their household Kris passes
Rose sitting in front of a globe that
has been turned to show Africa
showcasing that she views herself as
being a head of the continent they also
passed the statue of a wooden deer head
showing that Dean doesn't really hate
them as he has their form as an ornament
and therefore was lying he is of course
stabbed with a deer head later in the
movie showcasing the reversal of the
black book comment Dean also brings up a
photo of his father who he learned was
beaten by Jesse Owens in the qualifying
round for the Olympics we learned that
he didn't really get over it and it can
be gathered from this conversation that
this was the event that made his father
believe that African Americans were
superior we later see Walter running at
night and this is likely because he's
still obsessed with his loss he wears a
cap to hide his operations scar across
his forehead and the other people who've
also had operations carried this out -
this includes Andre who is now Logan and
he wears a hat and Georgina is seen
fixing her hair on a reflection and this
too could be to hide her scar when Chris
is out and about he also sees her in a
room adjusting a hell and again bringing
attention to this Dean points the
basement and says don't go down there
there's black mold
later in the film we learn that this is
where the lab is kept so this could
actually be a double entendre and he may
mean that there is a black mold kept
down there as in a mold for another body
we are introduced to Georgina and Dean
says that his mother loved a kitchen and
it keeps a piece of her in there he
never says what that piece is but as we
learn Georgina is his mother and
therefore this line holds an alternate
meaning at the table Missy asks about
Chris's mother who we know died in a hit
and run
she clinks his spoon against her glass
as he does it which sets off the idea of
Chris's mother being connected to this
it's the first use of suggestion in the
movie but this clink also breaks
Georgina out of her hypnosis for a
second and thus she is able to gain
control slightly she spills the drink
and it just gives away that some things
are not quite right with the character
now shoutouts for mr. Schock pants and
reddit for discovering this as I didn't
notice it but hats off there's a sign of
Georgina viewing chris is less than they
are as she refills the Armitage's
glasses first even though Chris's M
d and there's aren't silver spoons are
important as they are used as a way to
control Chris but they of course carry
with down the meaning of a silver spoon
which is a sign of privilege
Jeremy is introduced and he talks about
MMA pretty quickly almost seeming to
guide the conversation towards it he
tries to grab Chris and remarks on how
well he would do if he competed this
could hint and the fact that he wishes
to take his body from him and use it as
a way to become a sports star after the
awkward moment Rose brushes her teeth in
her ensuite next to a poster that says
death cheater which refers to how the
family wanted cheat death
Chris takes a trip outside before being
hypnotized by Missy within about Chris's
mother's death in full and how when she
died he was at home watching the TV he
said he did nothing whilst this happened
and he just sat there he was a passenger
that wasn't able to save her and we see
in the sunken place that he too is
adrift unable to really move whilst he
watches the events player before his
eyes on a TV screen as a child he
scratched his bed and as an adult he
scratches at the chair arms which
eventually saves his life Chris awakens
to find his phone has been unplugged
from its charger and Georgina did this
to make sure that I ran out of battery
when Chris talks to her we can also see
a sign beside his hair that says Chris
is dead
come on man they were telling you get
out we meet Walter outside and I seems
like a nice guy
how do fellow kids he of course uses
outdated slang like a real doggone
keeper that highlights he grew up in
another time period when the guests
arrived they all show up in black cause
perhaps suggesting that they wish to be
in a black vehicle they hug Walter
showing that he's more than just a
gardener and many of them talk and ask
questions based around things that
they're interested in an X Golf asks
Chris if he's ever played golf a woman
asks if black men are better in bed
whilst her wheelchair-bound husband sits
beside her and Jim Hudson a blind art
dealer clearly wants him for his eyes
Rose and Chris also wear clothing that
looks like they represent an American
flag and altogether there's just a weird
vibe about the entire thing I say that
because we mustn't let black people know
that we do this every weekend I keep
that keep that secret yeah it's here
that we meet Logan aka Andre from the
start and he has no idea what a fist
bump is which
reminds me of all the times I went in
for the shake and got the bump sometimes
you just don't know Logan is with a
woman much older than he is and this was
obviously his wife before the operation
he then paraded about and made to spin
around showing that it was a success
Chris takes a picture of Logan and this
triggers him into shouting get out hey
you missed that one didn't you Chris is
sure that he met him before and we
learned from his friend rod that he had
at this point they hold the auction for
him and this is very reminiscent of
slave auctions of old Jim wins and
Jeremy looks angry and I guess he'll
have to find another way to compete in
mm-hm
Rose promises to take Chris home but
it's all a ruse to buy more time and
Chris finds photographs of all her exes
these later appear behind her on the
wall above her bed during this scene
Rose also eats cereal with the milk
separate this shows the separation of
whiteness from a mix of colors
highlighting the views of the family
everything goes crazy and Chris is
knocked out and shackled bringing up the
imagery of slavery he manages to pick
cotton out of the chair which he stuffs
into his ears symbolizing cotton picking
which slaves were often forced to do now
it's during this that we cut to rod who
is trying to get into contact with him
we can hear an announcement for flight
237 which yep you guessed it is another
shining reference in the room that Chris
is bounded I did kind of get more
shining vibes from it too the layout is
very symmetrical and that is quite a
large characteristic of the set design
in that film the television set also
resembles the television set from the
shining to as we can't really see the
cable for it and it's somehow turned on
and playing Chris is playing a video
that explains everything and we can hear
the slogan a mind is a terrible thing to
waste this was a slogan for the United
Negro College Fund highlighting the
family taking black ideals and
subverting them
Jim's brain is cut open and I know that
brain ops tend to look like this but to
me it also resembles an egg a symbol of
birth perhaps hinting at the rebirth
process that he's about to go through
Chris breaks free and beats Jeremy with
a croquet ball which is meant to mirror
how he attacked him with a croquet bat
earlier in the film Dean is impaled with
the deer head and Jim is left paralyzed
as the fire begins commenting on the
same
ability that he wished to place upon
Chris Chris kills Missy and grapples
with Jeremy at the door similar to an
MMA fight almost and I guess I guess
Chris would be good at it
he even escapes a sleeper hold well done
Chris gets into the car finds Jeremy's
night helmet possibly being a symbol of
the Crusaders and the radio plays run
rabbit run which was present during the
abduction of Andre Chris hits Georgina
and takes her in the car she lashes out
at him and he crashes by the side of the
road whilst Rose in her grandpa try and
chase him down Chris flashes his phone
camera which we saw worked on Andre and
he snaps out of it and then shoots rose
before killing himself Rose apologizes
to Chris as he strangles her but he
stops when he realizes that she's taking
pleasure in it the flashing lights of
police then show and Rose reaches out to
them in the alternate ending this was
going to be the police and they would
arrest Chris for killing the family
showing police prejudice but in the end
appeal opted for it being rod in his TSA
vehicle he did tell him not to go in the
house to be fair the same song from the
title place and this is an ancient song
that when translated says to run that
ends the film and that's pretty much all
of the details in the movie and I had so
much fun watching this it's one of the
best Horrors ever and hopefully you
enjoyed the breakdown as well now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the film and if there's anything we
missed
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then make sure you
check out some of the insane details we
noticed in the haunting of Hill House
you point out all of the background
ghosts and hidden meanings so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want something else to watch if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to Ebert debate with heavy spoilers
so hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]